hello my name is William Hendricks I'm
an instructor at Mass General Hospital
Department of Neurology and I would like
to thank Thermo for inviting me to give
this webinar today and so what I would
like to do today is to talk with you
about genome editing tools for IPC based
disease modeling and so what I will do
in the next 20 25 minutes or so is give
you a broad overview of Beast and genome
editing tools and how we use them in our
lab and then I will finish off with an
example as to how we have been using
CRISPR cas9 genome editing to find a
causative mutation for a particular
disorder that we are studying in our lab
so
this is a slide showing an overview of
induced pluripotent stem cell technology
which was really a break through
discovery day made by Shinya Yamanaka
who found that by over expressing a
number is a few transcription factors
you could actually induce pluripotent
stem cells from adult somatic cells and
these induced pluripotent stem cells
like embryonic stem cells could then be
differentiated to pretty much any cell
type of the body and so especially for
the field of neurology neuroscience
this was a very important discovery
because before this discovery we did not
really have access to patient material
but now what we can do is derive somatic
cells from patients or controls deriving
disappear button step cells from these
and then differentiate these in a dish
towards different types of neurons and
so what we can do with these neurons for
disease modeling for example is really
look at basic and better biology of
particular disease or use these for a
drug screening or small molecule
compound screens
can also use this technology for self
therapeutic approaches as is evidenced
by some recent clinical trials where
retinal cells and for example
dopaminergic neurons have been derived
from clear pond stem cells with the goal
to transplant these cells eventually
into patients to eat or to restore
function
an additional important tool that has
been developed over the past decade or
so and that makes this this blue pod
stem cell technology even more powerful
is the event of genome editing and so
into some 2009 this was one of the first
papers from the English lab that showed
that by using custom engineered
nucleases you can actually target and
genes in human protein stem cells and so
one of the important reasons as to why
one once to genome edit button stem
cells and if for example I am looking at
a certain scientific trait that is
caused by a particular disease
associated mutation genomic background
or differences in genomic backgrounds
between my control cell lines and my
page cancer lines may actually skew my
readout of phenotypic traits that I'm
measuring and this is particularly the
case for very subtle phenotypic traits
now if I were to introduce a particular
mutation in a control cell or in using
genome editing tools I'd be able to
generate so-called as isogenic pairs of
cell lines and this would allow me to
keep the difference differences in
genetic background to an absolute
minimum vice-versa we can also introduce
or repair page limitations in patients
alliance in order to see if we can
rescue a particular phenotype caused by
this disease associated somatic variant
and so this last example for us in the
lab was really important to and discover
a causative genetic variant in a
disorder called x-linked dystonia
parkinsonism which I will talk about
later in this presentation
now for Gina
stem cells there are a number of genome
editing tools that are available to us
which depends a little bit on the
application you want to use include bone
stem cells for example if I'm interested
in knocking out genes and I would use an
endonuclease to introduce
double-stranded breaks in my pupil stem
cell line that is then repaired either
by two processes normally this end
joining or homology directed repair and
non-mothers end joining is really a
repair process that we rely on to
introduce gene knockouts
whereas homology directed repair is a
repair process in the cell that rely on
I'm going to want to introduce for
example snips or reporter genes another
recently developed tool to introduce and
slips or to repair snips in input on
stem cells or minion cells in general
are so called catalytically inactive
cast proteins that are fused to
enzymatic domains and that for example
can be used for so-called base editing
where we can change one base to another
for example I see two AP and this way we
can introduce a precise alteration and a
big advantage of this particular tool is
that we don't have to introduce a
double-stranded break in the genomic DNA
another tool that is available to us for
genome editing and is so-called
epigenome editing and so what we're
making use of here is casts proteins and
nucleases that again are catalytically
inactive but are refused to do for
example an activation or repression
domain and if we target these casts
proteins to enhancers or promoters then
we are able to modulate gene expression
and so these type of tools
are very convenient for for screening
for example screening purposes but for
the purpose of this talk I will focus on
the endonucleases that actually
introduced double-stranded breaks in the
cell
so some considerations protein editing
in group on stem cells
first of all you need to consider the
genome editing outcome whether you want
to introduce a knockout to knockout or
whether you want to introduce precise
repair snips or gene reports for example
because this also determines the
targeting range for example the
targeting range in order to knock out a
gene would be a little bit broader
because as long as I am in a early exon
or at least in exon that is shared
between multiple splice variants I can
introduce a double-stranded break that
isn't repaired by normals and joining
which results in insertions deletions at
the side of double-stranded break and
might introduce a early frame shift
resulting in early stop codon and
basically knocking out my gene of
interest however if I am interested in
putting a snip at a particular position
in a genome then my targeting range is
kind of constrained and this will also
determine often which has protein or
nucleus I am going to use another
important consideration is on purgative
activity how well does my guess 9 guide
RNA complex code and so here it is
important to really test three to four
different guides and see which one is
most active also an important point is
of target activity which I will go into
a little bit more later in the talk or
specificity if you will and so you
really have to check for off target
effects after your genome editing of
click on stem cells then another
consideration is delivery am I going to
introduce my editing system by use of
plasmids or arm PS am I going to deliver
these with based on lipids of lipid
based transactions or electroporation
and so these are all important things to
consider and so in our lab we typically
use these two types of cast proteins as
endonucleases we the workhorse still is
the gas 9 the wild pack has nine
variants that recognizes some 10 motives
accessing of ngg and so we also have
additional gas 9 variants that recognize
different pan bearings so this would
unable to increase our targeting range a
little bit and it has been estimated now
with all the different gas 9 variants
that there is a pan variant every two
base pairs so it is a very very
versatile gas 9 and the new case for
some applications we also use gas 12 a
formerly known as CB f1 and this one has
a different pan side and a slightly
different cutting pattern the advantage
of this particular cache is that you can
target T rich regions and has been
reported to be more specific than gas 9
so the chances of off target effects are
less when using gas 12 compared to class
9
typical workflow in our lab really is to
design guide RNAs online we then either
clone or order these guide RNAs for
example you can order guide RNA through
thermal or cyndago which can be used
together with either gas 9 in a plasmid
or more typically gas line protein
these are transfected into pupil stem
cells we often try to use a reporter for
example GFP to be able to enrich our
pool transfected purple stem cells these
are then sorted either single cells
sorted into 96-well plates or sorted as
bulk and then played it at clonal
density and then picked into 96-well
plates these are then split into sister
plates with one for genomic DNA analysis
and the other for clone recovery after
identification of successfully targeted
clones another
flow that we use in our lab is based on
the GDP see our method or digital
droplet PCR method and sip selection it
was described by the lab of boost
Conklin a couple years ago basically
here we transfect a pool of very potent
stem cells where we played the whole
pool in a 96-well plate we then do
digital droplet PCR and determine which
well has the highest percentage of gene
edits if this is already high enough
after the first selection we immediately
go to clonal density plating of this
particular well otherwise we would pick
this well and replay the cells in
another 96-well plate and do another
round of selection and then upon finding
the well with the highest number of
clean edits we would be played as well
and so you can basically reduce
screening from say hundreds of clones to
about five to ten clones in order to
find a number of successful targeted
clones and so with the guide and in a
donor template design what I've shown
here in this table are just a few
examples of websites that you can design
used to design your guides or your
talents as well as a website that it's
very helpful in designing guides or
templates with sila mutations to
introduce or remove restriction sites as
well as a website that helps you to
assess your genome edits
I design it is important to keep the
targeting range in mind many sites offer
the tool to predict on target activity
however in our hands is not always or
more often not than that it does
translate translate well into actual on
target activity in our salon that we are
targeting what is important though is to
pick the five or ten top predicted off
target effects and PCR around the region
sequences and see if there are any index
at that particular position
another important thing is to sequence
the target locus in your cell that you
want to target in your salon if you want
to target and plus nothing is more
annoying and finding out that your
genome editing strategy doesn't work
because there's a snip at your position
where you want to target your genome
editing system to
plate design we typically use single
stranded illegals if we want to
introduce snips or small deletions and
so therefore we order all egos that have
50 200 nucleotides homology arms on
either end make sure that the edits that
you want to make are within 10 base
pairs of the double-stranded break to
improve efficiency and it is also very
helpful to deduce a sign annotation
either for NGS based screening methods
or even restriction restriction analysis
based methods it's very helpful to
introduce a sedimentation in your only
go
large gene insertions we typically use
vector DNA or plasma DNA and depending
on the size of the insertion we have
homology arms on either end of 0.5 to 3
Kb
and so the
typical how to go experiment with like
in our lab we would transfer ourselves
and then about 48 hours later we would
short and then after plating we would do
for example a pcr-based screen where you
PCR around the region of of the double
strand break where you in the case of
knockouts want to observe in bills and
for HDR and what we typically do is
introduce this a limitation that
introduces a restriction enzyme side or
removes one we then do PCR and
restriction digest we run that out on a
gel and so this would give us potential
clones that we would then confirm by
Sanger sequencing and in this particular
panel I've indicated some potential
outcomes after normal modes and joining
where you have obviously wild-type loans
with no index on either allele you can
find heterozygous clones within Dells on
just one allele compound heterozygous
mutant clones which have in Dells on
bulk alleles but in slightly different
positions and then homozygous mutant
clones with the same end ELLs on both
alleles and important is that these in
Dells have to introduce a frameshift in
order to be able to knock out the gene
of interest
now with regard to off target effects
some words of caution a couple years ago
there were a whole flurry of papers that
showed dramatic off-target effects in
cancer cell lines and so the question
really was for Talon and Cass
mediated genome editing tools whether we
had the same issue in blue code stem
cells and so three independent studies
came out that actually showed that the
mutational load due to a crest from
crisper gas 9 or talent based genome
editing improve on stem cells was very
low if not non-existent and that most of
the mutations that were found in these
cell lines were actually due to
continued culture of Pierpont stem cell
lines
ever
there were two other papers that came
out very recently that actually caused
short-lived short-lived
sorry short-lived scare because now many
people thought that and genome editing
actually causes cancer but these two
papers actually showed the normal
biology of the cells upon introducing
DNA damage because what happens is that
we are introducing double-stranded
breaks using genome editing tools which
then obviously induces the p53 and
pathway in order to prevent cells with
too much DNA damage to live on and
become cancerous
so the takeaway message from these two
papers in my opinion is really you have
to look at the p53 gene and see whether
there are unintended mutations that may
be that may not be good for you or for
your cell lines on the other hand it it
also shows that actually if you will be
able to transiently inhibit the p53
pathway you might also increase your
genome editing efficiency but the main
takeaway is really to be careful and
discard any cells that have be
physically mutations and after genome
editing and so another thing I would
like to mention in this regard is that
awhile ago there was a paper by the even
lab that actually showed that a large
number of cell lines that are were
obtained from different laboratories and
actually already contains mutations in
p53 gene that also confirms confirms
from growth advantage of these cells or
other cells that do not have these
particular mutations
another paper that came out recently
again was this one where they showed
that Chris Berg has nine induced
double-stranded breaks and repair of
these breaks actually led to large
deletions and complex rearrangements and
again drives home the point that it is
very important to characterize your
salons and not only for off-target
effects based on your guide RNA but also
beyond that really look careful at your
carry type of your gene edited lines and
so what I hope done here to summarize
the first part is that it's important to
sequence genomic loss is aligned to be
targeted and look at all targets besides
nuclear action and neon transaction
requires ourselves an operation lipid
transfection has a better cell survival
as well as RP delivery when compared to
plasmid DNA based editing
characterization is very important to
look for stemless markers and
differentiation potential as well as
scary typing and off target effects like
I said these are less of an issue with
blue button stem cells compared to
cancer or immortalized cell lines but it
is important to check at least some of
the predicted off target effects and so
we have been using CRISPR cas9 to look
at this particular disorder x-linked
dystonia parkinsonism which is endemic
to the pen ions in the Philippines the
Mendelian disorder that's inherited in
an excellent recessive manner slowly
progresses from dystonia to parkinsonism
and the limited patient pathology shows
that there is a gradual degeneration of
the medium spiny neurons in the striatum
as shown in these panels a shows a
control that will be is a patient in a
dystonic phase
LLC is a patient in the parkinsonian
phase where there is a complete loss of
the mean spine in your arms and so
previous genetic studies we came up with
a number of candidates Kennedy mutations
but they were not able to really
pinpoint the causative mutation and many
it's not all of these variants were
found in introns of the transcription
factor test one so that one is a
transcription factor part of the DFTD
and transcription machinery and so one
of the likely mutations based upon our
own genetic studies was the insertion of
a retrotransposon in incheon 32 of that
one and so what we decided to do 3 do a
functional characterization of these
cells so we biopsied fibroblasts from 10
families we derived IPC's that will then
differentiate it towards induced knowns
based on over expression of neurogenic
to we different set these two NSCs and
NSE derived neurons and then we
performed RNA seek studies to look at
the transcriptional profile so
transcript assembly and have one
quantification when we look at different
transcripts we found known transcripts
but we also found the number of novel
transcripts in activity patients I would
like to focus your attention to this
particular one where it seems that some
intronic sequence just proximal of the
SVA and the retrotransposon insertion
it's being spliced to exon 32 so this is
a case of I've ever been aberrant
splicing and so when we looked at f1 we
found that that form was actually
reduced in xdp cells compared to
controls
we also looked at the error in splicing
and what we found was that in controls
we see in normal splicing effects from
32 to exon 33
whereas in ecstacy cells we see that
there is average splicing of intronic
sequence to exon 32 and so when we
quantify this we found that there was an
increase in this aberrant splice variant
in ecstasy patients compared to controls
and there was a clear correlation so
meaning that you have a high expression
of this aberrant splice variance you
have a lower expression of tough one
we decided to use a crisper cast line
approach to cut out this SVA so we
targeted we target it's personal and
this soul from the SVA we then generate
a number of Delta s VA lines which were
characterized the role character to be
normal and then when we looked at the
Aaron splice variant we were with we saw
that we were able to completely abolish
the error in splicing in this in the
Interphone and so when we come to Phi
this we saw that we have complete
abolishment of the in front 32 signal or
this aberrant splice variant then when
we look at to have one expression we saw
that we by excising out es PA we were
able to completely rescue the platform
expression so this is a clear example of
how we can use a genome editing tool to
really look at a positive mutation for
the disorder and really pinpoint a
particular causative mutation so in
summary here we showed that transcript
assembly in qualification show the novel
I've been splice variants and reduction
in tough one in xtp cells and that we
could rescue to have one expression by
excising of the SVA and we are currently
interested in looking at the potential
of RNA based therapeutics to correct
grammar in splicing that we find in the
phone and in these patients and so with
that I would like to end and just thank
the following people in the Tokarski lab
the channel Sheila and Adi the Bragg lab
David and alloy and from Keith Jones lab
bank on stever and will have been
instrumental in in this work MNH sei
announcer on chorus 1 and Chad Cohen and
I would like to thank you for your
attention